こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
初めて社長の
Amazonの
購入
履歴どうなってるの
はい過去に何度もやってます俺の
Amazonの注文履歴
購入履歴をみんなに見ようっていう
コーナーなんですけど何回かやってるん
ですけども最後にやったのが2020年の
12月の26日2020年までのやつは
もうみんなに見せてるんですけども
2021年2022年2023年がまだ
見せてないということでちょっと見ていき
たいと思いますほぼ記憶にないんですけど
もたいていの買い物Amazonで結構
ネットでやっちゃうんで割と俺の人生
みたいなところがあります今から皆さんは
俺のここに2年間の人生を見ます
刮目してください時刻が今深夜の1時半も
深夜テンションでやるよえー1個だけ寄せ
くださいあの僕の家族の皆さんは絶対に見
ないでください今すぐブラウザバックして
ください正直ねちょっとね自信がないね
自信がないっていうかもうなんか
怖い本当にあの
嫌わないでくれって言うのとこれが俺でっ
ていうのがはっきり出ると思います色んな
ちょっとあの僕の思考が詰まった漫画とか
も出てくるかもしれません非常に
恥ずかしいかもしれないけどもこういう
人間だと思ってぜひ見てくれで行こう
これで見れるのかじゃあ2021年の
購入品見ていきましょうかはいというわけ
で見ていきましょう2021年の注文品
ですねあーなんかでもここら辺は割と
まともだなPCR検査のキットを買って
ますねマスクとかお皿買ったりマスク買っ
たりPCRキットあマスク
遊戯王カードここら辺ちょっと遊戯王にお
熱な時期ですねあサウナも買ってますね
サウナあと動画用にあスイッチも買ってる
な動画用にやっぱりね変な買い物大量に
するのがやっぱYouTubeだっぽいよ
なこれなんか慌てるバブルっていう機械
24個買ってるな行かれてるマジで
偽付近コスチュームとか巨大な
ワイングラスとかかってますねこれ何
ツインスターってこれ
ニットセーターメンズタートルネックあ
なんかセーター伸びるから何枚切れるのか
みたいなやつをやろうとしたんですけど
結局やってないな
異常何を買ってるな買いすぎじゃないこれ
ニットセーターどこいったんだろう動画に
はしてないからなでもセーター何個切れる
のかなと思って買った記憶がありますあの
こういうコスプレとかも動画用なんだろう
な
遊戯王カード飾り用のなんかこういう家具
みたいなやつとかあここら辺もハルウララ
飼ってるねここら辺マジでなんかデッキ
作ろうとしてるなエアコン買ってます
[音楽]
これ単子あ上やばあぶねえ危ねぇじゃない
アウト自動カップ麺メーカー買ってますあ
やばいあやばいの来たやばいの来たこれ
やばいの来たあーこれやばいこれやばいわ
これやばいあった危ない危ないすっとあー
漫画がちょっと若干気になるところですが
これあのなんかあーやばいやばいどんどん
あやばいゲームボーヤでマウス買ってます
ね竹馬も買ってますね俺どういう精神状態
なんだこれなんかそのあのええエロエロと
なんかホビーが交互にこうなんか波打って
ますねこれ一定のリズムでまあちょっと
だけ説明させていただきますとこのおばさ
んっていうのはなんかそのいとこのおば
さんがそのたまに会うみたいな関係なん
ですけどもなんかそのおばさんにちょっと
あの興奮して
我慢できなくなっちゃってちょっとその
微妙に
あんまりここで話せないですあんまり
YouTubeで話せないんですけどその
総合が至る過程がすごい俺の
クリエイティビティを刺激したというか
すごい勉強になりました
遊戯のカツラとこの見せたがり乗ってる
やつはそんなになんかいい感じのやつでし
たひと夏の
これは普通にあの青春のものです外書一色
とかもあの程よいいい感じのセクシーな
漫画ですホワイトボードSDカード有料
カードポケット
趣味の時代ドラゴンではないよなこれこれ
ジンオウガですねBluetooth
ヘッドホンType-CのSDカードスっ
てやつ8分4枚あギガントここで呼んで
ますねこれはまあ若干エロいですけども
とても面白い漫画ですApple
Watchの液晶あーこれあれだ確かモン
ストで呪術廻戦が来ててまず内容を把握し
ようっていうので漫画を読んだり釘崎
野薔薇のコスプレも買ったんですけど確か
間に合わなくてこれ無理だったなモンスト
で呪術廻戦のガチャやるとき用のこれ
コスプレを買ってますね
はいこれなんかあれだ
ここで確かチョキのものたくさん置いて
ヒカキンさんのHIKAKINジャケで
チョキ出させる動画用にピースサインの
CDとか買ってますねMacBookの
なんかシールぬいぐるみああズームなんか
たまにホラー映画見たくなるんですよね
呪術廻戦ラストギアスこれは別にエロく
なかったからなんか普通にもう内容忘れ
ちゃったな無限ダイナのフィギュア買っ
たって進撃の巨人の最終巻を
呼んだりでここはカメラ系機材を買わ
なきゃというタイミングだったんでしょう
ね
痩せたいと思ってたような感じが見えます
カロリー0面の開まくってるね6個も買っ
てる
元ゼリーの映画を見て
遊戯王カードを買い100年メダルダイス
を3つも3種類も買ってる俺でナーフの
字を書いてドクターマーチの靴を買い
扇風機グリーンバッグ海辺の映像なんで
これなんかねちょっと映画で見たんです
けどなかなかちょっとねこれあの
内容覚えてないですねやばい記憶がねマジ
でないあといろんな作品見てるからでも
なんか面白かったですすごい綺麗な映画
だった記憶があるでもなんか人間関係は
ドロドロだったな全が20個買いSSD
これすごい大容量でデータ移すのに便利な
ので買いましたマイク充電器Apple
Watch山わさびの動画で使った東京
リベンジャーとこれバーって呼んでますね
あーっと
絡み盛りはいい漫画です個人的にあの高校
生のちょっとその思春期で若干性に興味が
あるみたいなところをうまいことついてで
もそれはなんか人と違うなと思って
よくよく分析したらあのしっかり人と違っ
てたというかファブルっていう漫画も
面白かったですねこれしっかり読ませて
もらってますすごい面白かった
ヤクザみたいな人が構成するみたいな感じ
なんですけど結局そうもいかないよって
いうあーやばい
彼女が不在の間彼女のやばいこれあのはい
次行きます
俺どういう精神状態なのちょっとこういう
漫画にならすぐ中華鍋買いたくなっちゃう
そしたらちょっとまた
ニュートラルに戻ってギャルと恐竜読み
始めてこれエンド用の骸骨ですねちょっと
レンズ買った後に50回目のファースト
キス買ってますねとっても好きな作品です
まだ遊戯王の波が来てあ遊戯をこう来てる
ねじゃパソコンのポケカも買いつつあと俺
どうしたんだこれなんか
コミュニケーション能力つけようとしてた
時もあったっぽいですねあこれ絶対風船の
企画だあここでリゼロコラボがあったん
ですよ確かモンストそれでレムのコスプレ
を買ってますねあパームスプリングスと
いう映画とっても僕好きですひよこを
持ち越したまま主人公だけが同じ日を永遠
に繰り返せるっていうめちゃくちゃ夢ある
映画ですとっても好きですこれスーパー
ボール爆買いしています前メディアさんの
コスプレでもこれも確かモンストかな
クワイエットプレイスを見てあ少年の
アビスねこれもなかなか
癖のある
漫画でしたかなり
泥沼のドロドロの
漫画ですぜひあの
闇を見たい人の真っ黒な部分見たい人は
読んでみてくださいすごくどす黒いです
円盤メイズってこれダーツの漫画ですね
あれあーこれ人妻の唇が気になっちゃって
んだ俺これその後パイの実勝ってる
でっかいジェンが勝ってヘッドフォン買っ
てあーこれレスこれレスの漫画ですね
なんかそういうなんか夫婦が不仲になった
後の
鳴った理由とかさ
立ち直る方法とか気になんないですか皆
さん恋人とかのそういう人のそういう事情
とか作品めっちゃ気になっちゃうんで別に
エロいのが見たいとかじゃないんですけど
普通になんでそうなったか喧嘩してしまう
んだったら何でそうなってしまったかどう
やって復縁するのかとかやっぱ人と人との
その関係性作品から垣間見えるのでそう
いう部分僕楽しいんですよね東京
リベンジャーズ新作出て買ってます
ここら辺はなんか何だったんだろうこれ
なんか色々物騒なもの買って俺どうした
また
[音楽]
友達のお母さんとその後マジックカーマ
勝ってんだからどうしたんだ4つもまあ
なんかタイ使ったりエンターキーのでかい
の買ったり王様ランキングな漫画を一気
飲みしてこたつを買ったとまあまあパン
なんか完全色買ったマネキン20個買っ
たりあトリックアート買ったり
服を整理したかったんだろうね
ケーブルあ呪術廻戦の新作買ってえー
クリスマスに最後
呪術廻戦の18話を買って2021年を
終えておりますなるほどなるほどまあまあ
まあまあまあまあ
こんな感じですYouTubeっぽい
でしょいたってそれなりにちゃんとした
作品も読みますしちょっとそういう
セクシーなのも読ませていただいてますよ
じゃ次2022年いきます2023年まだ
とっておこうか早速お正月から通り目の
続きが気になってますねあそしてヒロアカ
のアニメも見ていますビデオカメラの充電
器を買った後突然
千と千尋の神隠しのボーちゃんのネズミの
姿のやつを19個かかってるマジで俺狂っ
てるな外付けハードディスクを2個買った
後にトリックアートを買った後に
MacBookProの充電器ここら辺
筋トレの部屋作る時用の多分床を買って
ますねこれヒロアカの漫画
バーっともうアニメだけアニメ見てて多分
止まんなくなっちゃって先を知りたくて
漫画を一気に読んじゃってますねこれ1月
の終わりぐらいに
いやめっちゃ楽しかった記憶がある
[音楽]
あこれあれですね
ダンジョンとすごい
面白かったです
田中って
机買ってまた僕のヒーローアカデミア
マイクあこれですサードサード呼んでます
ねいろはすをはいこれ多分みんなのために
買ってんだあの会社のマット買ってまた
なんかカメラの機材買いつつカメラここら
辺はマッドマッドマッドマットよ動画の
ものを買ったりねプロミシング
ヤングウーマンあでこれも動画のために
なんか部屋の角に置くと部屋が虹色に光る
照明めっちゃ買って動画にしました100
日間行くための映画を見て接着剤買ってT
シャツ2枚独創的ですね壁紙水風船買って
体重
計買ってあっここら辺多分ね痩せようと
思ってた時あれれれギャルと恐竜の流れで
またちょっと不純なもの読んでるぞこれ
これなんかパパがお父さんが自分の娘の
女の子がいるんですけどもその自分の娘の
友達をちょっとそのあの
これもすごいですよ面白いですからぜひ
読んでみてください
少年のアビスの新刊
秘密の刃ここら辺でバーっともう最後まで
読んじゃいましたね竜とそばかすの姫を
合間に挟みつつこんな人生は絶対嫌だって
いう漫画ちょっと
ダークな話が好きなんですよその
闇を知るのが好きでそういう漫画そういう
の多分楽しんじゃってるんだろうなあ
突然またパッと仕事に戻ってあーブラッド
ハーレーの馬車っていうのはちょっと
あまりおすすめしないですかなりあの
グロい感じでしたね愛と呪いヒロアカの
最新話を読みつつもあここでハイキューの
波がパーッときてバチバチにはまってます
ねん
サタンのファンに怪しいですねちょっと
まだこれまず大丈夫かこれ幸せな家族これ
もちょっとねそう家庭が崩れる系の漫画
だった気がしますすごい楽しかった僕だけ
がいない町の4話買ってますねあここら辺
ももうちょっと
夏に向けて色々買ってるな今日もいっぱい
出たね偉いよオジピ
何が出たんですかね突然飲む
紫外線の薬を買ったりこれは最近使ってる
乳液ですねフミーディフェンスハーネス
買ってでっかいコカコーラのボトル買って
スパイファミリーの漫画を読んでますね
ティスタっていう漫画も読んでるあここ
サンダル買って光る石タイムカードですね
会社用にここら辺も動画用に色々ハンド
スピナー系をバーって買ってますねこれ
全部ハンドスピナーなんですごくない人の
影響で動画のやつを買ったりあプラダの
帽子も買ってますねそうなんか2022年
でプラダに目覚めた年だったんよ
Amazonで買うこともあるし普通にお
店で買うこともありますかっこいいんだよ
ねシンプルでおカメラ系買って広場の最新
話
マンフロットカメラバッグ用のキャリー
バッグ買ってます
除湿機そんなゲームボーイアドバンス突然
やりたくなって買って呪術廻戦の最新話あ
これ絶対あの
旅の買って
めちゃくちゃいいこれ顔面のパック買って
バスケットシューズとサポーター買って
ここでメイドインアビスの波がバーッとき
て最新話まで一気に読みましたでカーテン
と机があったよここまたかあれあたまるは
ねこれ俺めっちゃ好きでした
玉の輿ロワイヤルっていう
めちゃくちゃ金持ちの男の人を好きになら
せたら玉の輿成功みたいな女の子たちの
その人生をかけたロワイヤルバトロワなん
ですけど
めっちゃドロドロというか普通にもう何で
もありのバトルでめっちゃ面白かったです
意外性もあってとても好きな漫画でした
三脚買ってコンセント買って秒速5
センチメートル鑑賞に浸りたくなったかあ
ここで親愛なるボケ殺意を込めてあの山田
涼介君のドラマ出させて頂いたやつの
やっぱ知らないといけないから原作を
しっかりと読ませていただきました
めっちゃ面白かったことの反応には4月は
4月は君の嘘読んでる光るマスクなんかね
あー
監視カメラあとねなんかねミニチュアに
はまっちゃって動物サウナとかなんか
サウナの1/10スケールのやつとか買っ
てました
乳液また取り入れてはげ予防のシャンプー
も買い家にシャンプーの椅子がないことを
削ってえっとカメラを買い机を買いカメラ
系参加ください
巨大ビーチボールスイッチの
コントローラーたくさん買いましたこれ
ポケモン発売したから買ってた記憶がある
発泡スチロールの偽物を買ってなんか
YouTuberっぽいことしてるなー
学生服も大量になんか学生学校の動画撮り
たくなったんだろうね高かったでスイッチ
ライトを買って動画用にメタルさえも買い
まくりgopro買ってカレーせんべいを
買って2022年を締めくくっておりまし
た
そんななんか超アダルトな漫画読んでる
わけじゃなくちゃんと内容があるでしょ
その玉の輿が主になってるとかただ意外と
その作品っていうかそのなんかなんかその
何だろうそういうの楽しんでるというより
ストーリー性作品のストーリー性をマジで
楽しんでるというかシチュエーションなん
ですよね私が求めているそのブっていうの
は
勘違いしないで欲しいなとは思ってます
けどもはいえっと僕の2021年2022
年はこんな感じでした
[音楽]
恥ずかしいでもなんかこれもう2年に1回
やってるからちょっと今後もやるね次の
動画は
20232024年版ですね2025年
ぐらいにお会いしましょうではごめん
なさい見ないで
[音楽]